>> Sean: SARAH SANDERS, GREAT
COURAGE TODAY GOING ON THE VIEW
AS SOME OF THE COHOST DIDN’T
WANT TO HEAR ANY OF IT WHEN
SARAH SPOKE ABOUT THE MOB
VIOLENCE, DEMOCRATIC RUN CITIES
FOR DECADES.
TOO MUCH FOR JOYLESS TO HANDLE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE WORST PLACES WE HAVE
THESE PROBLEMS ARE WHERE
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN ALLOWED TO
LEAD.
WE ARE FINALLY STARTING TO CLEAN
THIS MESS UP, STARTING TO MAKE
THINGS BETTER.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT WHO HAS
EMPOWERED THE AFRICAN-AMERICAN
COMMUNITY.
WE HAVE THE LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT
FOR BLACK AMERICANS, HISTORIC
FUNDING, OPPORTUNITY ZONES.
>> IT’S ONLY AN HOUR SHOW.
>> Sean: HERE AND NOW COME OFF
A BRAND-NEW BOOK JUST OUT TODAY,
SPEAKING FOR MYSELF, FAITH,
FREEDOM, AND THE FIGHT FOR OUR
LIVES INSIDE THE TRUNK
WHITE HOUSE.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR SARAH
SANDERS.
I DON’T KNOW HOW YOU DID YOUR
JOB AS PRESS SECRETARY.
I DON’T KNOW HOW
KAYLEIGH McENANY DOES IT.
COULDN’T PAY ME ALL THE MONEY IN
THE WORLD BUT THEN YOU TAKE IT
TO THE VIEW, REALLY?
A LOT OF COURAGE THERE.
AND I DIDN’T LIKE IT VERY MUCH
WHEN I REMINDED THEM AS I WAS
TALKING ABOUT THE PROBLEMS
OF ALL THESE MAJOR CITIES WHO
WAS THE ONE THAT WAS
LEADING THOSE MAJOR CITIES?
IT WAS VERY INTERESTING THAT
THEY STARTED NAMING OFF ALL THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND ALL THE
THINGS THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS
DONE TO EMPOWER THE BLACK
COMMUNITY, THEY QUICKLY CUT ME
OFF AND IT WAS TIME TO MOVE ON.
LET’S NOT FORGET THAT ONE OF THE
HOSTS OF THAT SHOW ACTUALLY
CALLED THE PRESIDENT A TERRORIST
DESPITE THE FACT --
>> Sean: WHICH ONE WAS THAT?
I PROBABLY MISSED THAT.
>> THE ONE YOU CALLED JOYLESS.
YES.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THE
PRESIDENT DID THE LAST FOUR
YEARS WIPING THE MOST DANGEROUS
TERRORIST OFF THE FACE OF THE PL
DEFINITION OF HYPOCRISY AND
THEY’VE DECIDED THAT THEY HATE
THIS PRESIDENT MORE THAN THEY
LOVE THIS COUNTRY AND IT HAS
NEVER BEEN MORE EVIDENT THAN THE
FACT THAT THEY CAN’T BE HAPPY
ABOUT THE POSITIVE THINGS THAT
THIS PRESIDENT HAS DONE TO HELP
ALL AMERICANS PARTICULARLY BLACK
AMERICANS ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
>> Sean: I LOOK AT THE
ENTHUSIASM IN NORTH CAROLINA
TONIGHT, AND I DON’T SEE THAT
FOR JOE BIDEN.
I LOOK AT THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS,
THEY CAN’T ACKNOWLEDGE A SINGLE
THING DONALD TRUMP HAS DONE WELL
BECAUSE BIDEN AND OBAMA DIDN’T
SET RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT,
DIDN’T DO OPPORTUNITY ZONES,
JOE’S RECORD ON RACE, 13 MILLION
MORE AMERICANS ON FOOD STAMPS,
8 MILLION MORE IN POVERTY, THE
LOWEST PARTICIPATION RATES AND
SEE ’70s AND THEN THE IRANIAN
DEAL, 150 BILLION.
I DON’T THINK THAT’S A GOOD
RECORD TO RUN ON.
>> NOT AT ALL AND IF YOU DON’T
BELIEVE ME, JUST LISTEN TO
JOE BIDEN DURING THE PRIMARIES,
ACTUALLY POINTED OUT HOW BAD
JOE BIDEN’S RECORD WAS WHEN IT
CAME TO RACE RELATION DURING HIS
ALMOST FIVE DECADES IN PUBLIC
SERVICE.
HE HAS DONE NOTHING AND ALMOST
50 YEARS TO HELP BLACK
AMERICANS.
WHY SHOULD WE EXPECT HIM TO DO
THAT NOW?
THE CONTRAST IS CLEAR AND
DONALD TRUMP NEEDS TO BE
REELECTED IN NOVEMBER.
>> Sean: AND BRINGING US
INSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE ON THE
REAL DONALD TRUMP READ I READ